es ist wieder soweit in meinen kühnsten
köpfe der wissenschaft und der essen
szene haben sich hier getroffen um zu
sodastream was das zeug hält das erste
video war scheinbar sich nie habe es
sehr gefeiert sehr sehr viele leute
haben das video geschaut des handelstags
belassen es nicht lumpen greifen gas
tief in die getränkekiste und hole mir
die wildesten sachen hervortritt
es ist so wie beim letzten mal musste
erstmal testen ja ja ich höre wenn du
das war eine tastatur stellt wie sauber
die ist einfach denkst du dir so dass
jung könnte diese flasche und geldwerte
auf deren basis direkt ich sage ja
richtig sagt ja ihr seht was das für die
power hatte ich habe wieder den ganz
frischen zylinder golfprofi auf einem
letzten mal darfst du wieder ziehen oder
flaschen wo wir zu sticken bisher nicht
ich habe sagen da machen wir auch ein
bisschen angst und ich hoffe du fängst
mit was den sparten bitte ok ja dass ich
das ist einer meiner favoriten power ich
stelle hier gibt's ja ich würde sagen
das geht wissen das jetzt mal auch
probeweise und fünf schmeckt genauso
heißt wie damals galt für sportler
ich glaube das erste mal es ist nämlich
genauso wie generell in usa und das
treten beim sport dieser geist krank
weil das so hier in sucht ohne und
irgendwas das bild bringen also sponsor
vertreten
nein weil das nur wüsste überschritten
hat
irgendwie muss die aussagen nicht gut
für dich das blau bis heute das gefühl
da brauchst du eine eigene oder und
schon gar nicht wenn du dich cdu ist
mord ganz ehrlich das sieht so crazy aus
also ganz ehrlich dass sie so geil aus
und irgendwie habe ich auch die hoffnung
dass gut schmeckt aber ich kann mir
keinen schwulen vorstellen durchgeblickt
was meist immer den kamera anklicken ein
café eine stufe wie wir für unsere power
ja muss muss ballacks dann ist das für
uns eine ganz klassische stufe 2 oder ja
so ist doch das liegt eigentlich der
große dort oben drauf und hat gut
geklappt des übels es ihm übel ist geil
aus wenn ich dann übrigens jetzt teppich
inzwischen drunter liegen würde das nur
kurz du hast du sagen können auch andré
glaube aus unserer langjährigen so dass
vielmehr müssen wir abwarten ist das
jetzt so hoch gezogen ist wir sind
nämlich kluges wir sind klug kraftsport
rainer schöner stufe würde ich mal
darauf bin ich ernsthaft gespannt wie
schmeckt das jetzt wohl bekomms trifft
es intensiver dadurch das recht auf
jeden fall willkommen die auf euer das
ist ja wirklich lecker einmal wirklich
lecker schmeckt wie sowieso ein lipton
vom geschmack hat jemand mal so lebten
hier ausgeschlossen
blau ist und einfach nur geld so das hat
noch niemand gemacht konnte ich glaube
das war wirklich das leckerste was wir
heute trinken werden ich habe ganz große
einst dazu eine bestimmte
verschiesst aber nur so kann ich diese
frage beantworten und diese angst nehmen
oder bestätigen weiß schon von der
flasche
nein durch das schlimmste genommen du
weißt camcorder strich wird ein mega
aggressiv dass ich bin täglich
max huber kräuterschnaps mag es ist
einfach nicht verstehen warum das ist so
falsch
boa sr drs spirituose von der mann kurz
die will man wieder trinken es könnte so
schön sein das könnte einfach da sein
oder war das schon ganz gut das schmeckt
aber ich liebe sex oder wenn wir es
hinter uns
juli ist das noch einmal eskalieren das
ging jetzt ab 1 kommt langsamer jetzt
kommt vor
ja das habe ich nun wirklich immer
abwarten dass hier so hochkommt die was
soll ich überhaupt jetzt richten ihr
dran
das wird ihr auch
es wird ja auch beginnen sobald und so
wird es ja ein teil meiner realen wert
der milch macht unterdrückt damit den
hoch nicht übrigens gewinnt muss doch
richtig gibt nicht so viele ja ist doch
okay wir machen uns für euch ja
meer sprudeln
deshalb solle nicht mehr gebraucht da es
sieht irgendwie so faszinierend raus
ganz kurzen meinem ticket shop in
frieden jetzt noch mal diesen
sommerferien beginnt jetzt wieder
gesehen
der ist erst video gesehen alle auch mit
tollen stimmen wir können kein zweiter
gemacht und kriegt so das für mich auch
noch haben aber noch mal bekommen und
jetzt ist es wirklich ein strudel
das hat so viel schlimmer war oder davon
sind dieses eklige von jedermann ich
habe sogar mal bist du in deine zunge
ein wirst du zu dem hals einfach aber
ich werde schon landet und was das
zweistöckige terrorliste werden
eigentlich nehme aber ich bewertet
einmal bis 06 schulnote wirkte er das
wirklich scheiße wir müssen uns einmal
festhalten für die menschen laufen ist
macht ist einfach schlechter bei 50
likes wird macht das jetzt echsen danke
2020 nicht krieg tränen in die augen
einfach nächste sache übrigens eine
sache die ganzen positiven endlich oft
gewünscht aber die konnte ich nicht in
den rucksack reintun ihr werdet sehen
wenn ihr dran sein aber es wird uns auch
keinen großen spaß machen
ich habe mir das denn interessant da
sagst du dir mal die leute dass wir bier
noch bulliger mama papa das ist uns aber
jeder macht eine pause
musstest du das kleiner wissenschaftler
vom feld wenn man in einem tiefsee u
boot eine cola flasche öffnet dann
spritzt diese nicht auch wenn man sie
schüttelt weil der atmosphärische druck
zu hoch und relativ vorsichtig
einschenken hier weil wir wollen
natürlich nicht dass der bestehende
sprudel verloren geht alles bisher war
okay aber so was mit dir mit kölsch zu
machen um ein gott defekt hat auch dass
das keine gute idee sein würden nein das
sind jetzt richtig doofe idee aber ein
bisschen mutiger stellte vielleicht
gehöre nicht nur vom tablet also nicht
warum drehen wir das eigentlich schon
wieder bei mir ja also es wird sowieso
komplette explodieren und sagt jetzt
schon blind ich habe auch machen das
wird richtig darum kann man das beenden
das ihr ernst es geht
das funktioniert
das gehört dazu kommt das drückt jetzt
erstmal jetzt der der schau mal richtig
kommt nicht ab und soja macht es leide
das wo ich es gar kein problem also da
ist überall bier drin ich muss mal kurz
parlamente beste das ich unbedingt auf
dem skandal vorbeischauen dafür dass er
mich das hier machen lässt und führt mit
mir für euch für euer entertainment hier
sein büro auseinander nimmt er macht die
besten bestellen videos auf youtube
guckt er ja auf jeden fall und immer
auch sonst sehr viele gute videos kein
kamen weil kein problem sage ich wir auf
unsere mittel und wege noch mal geklappt
in unseren körper zu pumpen
ja ich glaube das wird einfach
abgestandenes bier oder halt so ein
hübsches wir jetzt den geschmack und das
ist nun mal holen so wirklich der
geschmack ist so beck also ich glaube so
etwas schmeckt nicht nur schminke berufe
stimmt stimmt das 1 1 wie man der anti
alkohol kampagne ganz viel her ist halt
weg durch die größere oder heute einfach
körper auf die schweiz habe ich gedacht
jetzt einfach am boden aber schmecken
life 4 trifft so wir haben noch das eine
oder andere glas gebaut ist das wieder
lebhafte gezwungen als allerletztes sind
die leute ein bisschen
weihnachtsstimmung aufkommt habe ich mir
das ganz nett ist für euch über die
grünen teil trinken immer eine sehr gute
idee
nebenbei eine sehr gute idee e mail
extrem viel
das hab ich überhaupt keine gute idee
ist mir irgendwie vorstellen kann dass
es schmeckt das frühstück zwei kommen
dass du in der händlerschaft dem wasser
computer weil das sport und soll das für
sie genauso auf der schau werden müssen
ist geil auf als man denkt jetzt das ist
so eine rhabarber genre das assoziiert
mit geeilt war aber beruflich bin ich
natürlich geil wird es schmeckt genauso
wie er war also vielmehr zimt das - dem
zimt und ein bisschen bisschen unter
aber so schmecken dass diesem ein bürger
nämlich auch davon habe ich mir nur so 2
liter flaschen geholt und noch bis zum
bäcker hauptdeich dürfen wir noch dabei
nur dann schad- und frisches
plattengrenzen oder das ist angeht bild
haben antwort auf hugo ist geil
das ist meine überraschung heute safe
ist bei mir 10 15-11 crazy lag die
vielleicht 5000 kriegt ihr dass sie
jetzt wenn jetzt 5000 like sind darin
und so die ersten leute die diese hätten
eine lange habe ich ja einen setzen also
möglich die auf 2020 gibt es noch gute
überraschung kandidatur nicht einen
tätig kann so viel sagen wir bleiben
langsam dem ende zu also kurzprosa weißt
du was ich mir wünsche dass es schmeckt
wie sekt mit rosa m breit ist dass du so
trieb ein bisschen wie darf weder auf
sich gestellt was wenn wir so
tonaufnahmen machen könne drei finde ich
habe ihn geschlagen
er geht aber gar nicht durchziehen
schnell macht doch nicht was kann es
nicht 18 hallo hier ist aber ein lecker
was reden heute ab alter wäre wilderei
sind keine sachen weil sie das schlecht
die sonne ordentlich aber auch jürgen
grund wird diese sprudelt er nicht erst
klatschte geil wie südzucker arme
reversion in china hat skype in manchen
situationen wäre dass dadurch nicht
besser als ich will es auch besser ist
ein aufgesprühte rosa geiler als nur
orangen sagt scholle und da würde ich
ganz klar sagen jaja die wehr füße wäre
aus mehr süßes fleischer
was könnten sich dieser psychopath
gedacht haben als er gerade eben gesagt
hat dass sie eine sache vorbereitet
haben die aber nicht ist die antwort
lautet kaffee es riecht nach genau dem
was man braucht nachdem man sich seinen
magen schon mit aufgesprühten
jägermeister und aufgesprühten im
orangensaft verdorben hat deshalb das
uns schnell ein film 840 meter tiefe 2
und ich hoffe ihr wieder mit
da habe ich jetzt gerade die neueste
kaffeekreationen erfunden
wir sind drauf weil kommt zur new york
city um eine feste stütze welchen aspekt
dass mein gott was pferde waren
das schmeckt so wirst du im teebeutel
sind überdimensionale bord nehmen
das schützt du so ein bio müll rein und
dann hast du das jetzt scheiße leute
kurzfristig ist es vorbei mit dem video
heute dass es den kaffee hammer dahinter
mit der marke piaggio würden laut takacs
uhr jetzt was wäre
hier wollte ich aber auch geist kann
verstehen dass so was in die kommentare
verwechselten nicht müde wurden leicht
zu bekommen also haben wir überraschend
gewesen mit auch noch sollte man nicht
über tritte schwere nicht über gestalten
das geht nur mit hier ich hätte jetzt
mal acht leute ja ich damit leicht
dargereicht dank überreicht
das ist was wird es neben dem heute
probiere frage allein beim cockpit zur
referenz zu haben die buckelige milch
schmeckt ist so widerlich oder die
gleitschirme vor aber jetzt kannst du
dazu noch sagen wenn irgendwas ist was
ich daran erinnert das schmeckt wie
menschen sie hauptgeschäft ist also was
war der vorher selbst mal wieder 100.000
von diesen dieser art von video dann
kannst du mich dass er bei büro gegeben
hat dass er seine leber wasser ist
einfach alle seine organe gegeben
gebeten organhändler soll daraus macht
nur bis zum nächsten mal wir reden uns